hey we we had a a great debate last week
i want to get your take on it i think i
know where you're going to fall on this
but i just want to hear you say it
we were talking about lakers and celtics
both now with 17 championships and
michael smith was saying the lakers are
the most important team
uh in the nba i think something like
that most important to the nba nba
culture
and i said look it's the lakers and
celtics it's the lakers and how do you
feel
well first of all um
you'll never see me praise the celtics
in any form or fashion
uh and the league is the lakers it is
all about the lakers the most winningest
franchise in the league's history we've
been to the first time the most it's
time the most times
every jersey
every sock every ball every camera every
backboard has a laker on it they can't
escape it it is what it is and it ain't
what it ain't and it ain't the celtics
so you know like the league is better
when the lakers are winning you look in
our raptors and you got top 50s all
through out there there's
crazy there's really no fighting it you
know i know everybody
everybody wants to get on laker fans
because oh you had to wait 10 years all
10 years and so long
you know what i'm sorry i'm not a
phoenix sun i'm sorry i'm not a memphis
grizzly
or a washington wizard or or the hornets
or the knicks or i'm a laker bro it's
unacceptable a decade without winning
and now we here and y'all get to hear my
mouth until tip-off of the next season
it's gonna unplug that
well no but but help me uh that actually
helped me understand that because the
pep see i got a couple of pet peeves man
i don't like i don't like random number
anniversaries all that people tell me
it's the third anniversary of the
seventh anniversary is like nah five ten
that's one pet peeve another pet peeve i
have
is
hey it's the lakers first championship
since 2010. i mean you're right for no
that's not that long ago to people like
me but you said in your instagram video
it was 10 annoying years so
stay with that for a second like why was
why was it such a
why was it so difficult to go ten years
shay without a championship like most
franchises don't even taste one in a
lifetime so tell me tell us why that was
so difficult
well you know those players on those
franchises should probably be lakers um
it works out pretty good for you
uh yeah i'm a laker bro i don't know
what the draft lottery is i don't like
like i don't like
like recording the lottery and waiting
for ping-pong balls and
getting nervous and
like
you got to see how the other half is
i'm that's not me but
you know i don't like chilling that way
and so it was foreign territory and
y'all could have all that i think y'all
should really name the draft after the
clippers they've been there so much i it
just felt like
i was on enemy lines you know and it's
just it just made me uncomfortable i i
enjoyed the playoffs
it's like i like you being such an
accomplished actor
you've been such an accomplished actor
you're being such an accomplished actor
i think you'll appreciate this you know
who the lakers were for the last 10
years
y'all were dan aykroyd in trading places
that's a y'all yeah
y'all gotta yo yo y'all got to see what
the other half felt like
and now you're looking good billy ray
now you're like
now you're back on top you know yeah
lobster lobster crack crab now for
everyone
i forgot how stressful the playoffs are
and i i have at least four white hairs
somewhere in this fro
and i'm just happy it's over i can relax
kick my feet up
watch football and just not trip
hey man this is this is my final one for
you i'm a this is like an alley-oop if
you've ever gotten one
what is your final message
to the los angeles clippers
oh boy
you know
you guys really tried to switch it up on
me
it was all staple center love
until you let that celtic
come down here and coach y'all and pump
you all up to divide the city now you're
leaving staples center because you're
too weak to put up a banner in there
you're running from the sparks you're
running from the lakers especially but
let me tell you you can run as fast as
you can as far as you want to go
and we will always be in your ear
reminding you that you are trash
you are trash and you you hypnotize
these players with dollar signs poor
kawhi leonard you could have had it all
brother you could have had it all
paul george you stay where you at i hear
they trying to trade you to new york but
now y'all got rid of doc who's your
coach and your gm and now y'all about to
scramble again
oh my goodness
you